so as the votes continue to be counted
in the 2020 presidential election it is
becoming more and more clear that donald
trump
really lost to joe biden by a
substantial margin this election we're
now seeing a difference of 3.8 percent
in the popular vote that's just over 5.9
million votes that's a margin that could
easily exceed
6 million votes by the time all of the
vote is counted
there are still some states new york
state is one example
17 of the vote in new york is yet to be
counted new york state estate that joe
biden won very easily so as we get
closer to 100 percent
in new york and a few other states we
could be looking at a 6 million vote win
for joe biden now with georgia not
everybody has called georgia yet
we're expecting news on georgia today
maybe by the time you listen to this
show or watch today's clips
uh georgia will have been fully
certified with georgia joe biden would
end up
with 306 electoral votes that's the same
number of electoral votes that donald
trump had in 2016.
now if you were one of the people who in
2016 said trump won by a landslide
when trump had 306 electoral and
lost the popular vote by nearly 3
million
if that was a landslide as trump has
proclaimed
as kellyanne conway has proclaimed and
many others
you have to concede that biden winning
with 306
and a 6 million vote margin
has to be a doubly large landslide right
now to contextualize this if we look at
most votes received in history
no candidate ever received more votes
than joe biden did
this year other than donald trump also
this year
before that were barack obama's two
elections in 2008 and 2012
followed by hillary clinton in 2016. now
in terms of the popular vote
margin of victory joe biden's victory
by nearly 6 million this year is the
15th
largest out of 59 presidential elections
so in the top
quarter of popular vote margins
certainly
up there nowhere near the size of some
of the landslide victories we've seen
richard nixon and ronald reagan's wins
for example in 1972
and 1984 those were by 17 and 16 million
votes respectively
not nearly that big but it is a very
solid win
and it comes at a time when the idea of
a mandate
and the idea of recognizing that your
opponent won
and now gets to govern that idea has
gone
in the trash and yet that's not what we
are actually
hearing at this point in time and of
course
when joe biden is sworn in as president
republicans aren't going to defer to joe
biden as
if he had a mandate i'm expecting some
of the biggest most
vile obstruction from republicans that
we will see
um uh for for a long time i think it
will be worse than under barack obama's
presidency even and there's a real
question as to whether joe biden
will even get to govern i think that
what joe biden will get to do
he will have the privilege of dealing
with republican obstruction for the next
however many years
and the real reward that joe biden gets
is going to be cleaning up donald
trump's messes and at this point as
donald trump has completely evaporated
he's
he's gone with the wind so to speak
nobody's seen trump for weeks at this
point other than the leath rang ceremony
and
briefly taking credit for vaccines
this is why so much is riding on the two
upcoming senate runoffs in georgia biden
will be cleaning up
big messes from donald trump and his
ability to do it will be greatly
impacted by whether democrats control
the senate or not now what's going on in
georgia
very tight both races in georgia are
winnable but they are very tight
you've got the incumbent kelly loffler
against raphael warnock race that one
right now
according to the latest polls we've
received this week it's 49 to 48
in warnock's favor three percent
undecided what does that mean
it means it's a tie that's that's how we
have to operate
the incumbent republican david perdue
versus democratic challenger john ossoff
race
it's currently 49.49 with two percent
undecided it's a tie these races
are winnable but we have to get involved
in them so let's actually go through
what we can do
we're going to be talking about these
races quite a bit i will be covering
debates
if there are any it seems david perdue
has already turned down participating in
debates against john ossoff
we will be covering live results on
january 5. we're taking these two races
very seriously
if you live in georgia you must register
by december 7th
uh as long as you will be 18 years old
by january 5 you can register to vote if
you're 17
right now but you will turn 18 by
january 5th you can register to vote
right now we're linking uh in the
description to the youtube clip
uh for where you sign up and register to
vote in georgia now
early voting starts december 14th you
can request
absentee ballots until november 18th
we are linking to the page on which you
can do that as well
if you are in georgia you can volunteer
to safely knock on doors and get out the
vote
you can volunteer to be a poll watcher
or to monitor the processing
of ballots and then if you live out of
state
you can still help you can phone bank
you can text bank
if you want to find out more about that
you can text fair
fair 270700
that's the fair fight action group
and you can also donate to rafael
warnock
and or john ossoff as well so there's
plenty that we can all do
these two races ultimately could decide
what do the next two years look like
for a joe biden presidency we cannot
pass i don't want to overstate the
importance of these races unfortunately
i couldn't possibly do that
because these races are of uh of
ultimate importance right now so we're
going to continue talking about that
um for the next several weeks and all
the way through january 5th